c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir 25 ans de prison à
l'encontre de paul brousse et sa bague
in bag in à la cour d'appel du rwanda a
confirmé ce lundi la condamnation pour
terrorisme de l'ancien hôtelier rendu
célèbre par le film hôtel rwanda les
détails dans un instant le kenya frappés
par une pénurie d'essence conséquences
de la guerre en ukraine après les villes
de province c'est au tour de la capitale
a manqué de carburant les automobilistes
cherchent désespérément une station pour
faire le plein c'est l'activité
économique qui en fait les frais nous
serons à naïrobi dans ce journal
ce soir nous parlerons idir une langue
une poésie une mélodie une histoire
celle de l'homme qui a fait connaître la
culture kabyle à travers le monde mais
aussi l'histoire de ceux qui l'ont
côtoyé celle des contrées qui va fouler
et de l'émotion qu'il a donné un échange
avec farid alilat l'auteur de idir un
kabyle du monde il est notre invité ce
soir
il n'était pas présent à la lecture du
verdict paul rousset sabbagh inna a été
condamné à 25 ans de prison pour
terrorisme par la cour d'appel du rwanda
l'ancien hôtelier est fervent opposant
de paul kagame avait été rendu célèbre
par le film hôtel rwanda lui et sa
famille ont toujours démenti ces
accusations et dénonce un procès destiné
à museler un opposant les précisions de
notre correspondant à kigali simon
wohlfarth
statu quo pour paul rousset sabah guy
nadon la peine a été confirmée par la
cour d'appel à 25 ans d'emprisonnement
pour avoir fondé appartenu au front de
libération nationale le fln ce groupe
armé accusé d'avoir mené des attaques
meurtrières au rwanda entre 2018 et 2019
une peine égale à celle prononcée en
première instance par les juges et qui
ne répond une nouvelle fois pas aux
réquisitions du procureur qui demandait
la prison à perpétuité
les juges ont estimé que paul
rusesabagina était un primo délinquant
et qu'il n'était donc pas nécessaire
d'alourdir la peine paul rusesabagina a
toujours démenti ces accusations contre
lui et dénoncé un procès destiné à mu
les un opposant au président rwandais
paul kagame ce verdict a été critiquée
par la famille de paul rusesabagina qui
estiment qu'il a été rendu par une cour
partiale aux ordres du pouvoir cette
décision de la cour a eu lieu en
l'absence du principal intéressé qui
boycottent la procédure depuis des mois
ce bilan délivré par les forces armées
maliennes les femmes à ont affirmé
vendredi soir avoir tué deux sans trois
combattants de groupes armés terroristes
lors d'une opération dans une zone
sahélienne du centre du mali mené du 23
au 31 mars de son côté la communauté
internationale se dit préoccupé sur de
possibles exactions commises au mali par
des soldats maliens compagnie de
mercenaires du groupe privé russe wagner
l'effet papillon de la guerre en ukraine
sur les automobilistes kényan le pays
connaît depuis plusieurs jours une
pénurie d'essence ce sont d'abord les
villes de province qui ont été touchés
puis en aérobie la capitale depuis ce
lundi 7 et nury paralyse les
déplacements et l'activité économique
les précisions de notre correspondant
bastien renouil
cette station service est l'une des
rares à nairobi être réapprovisionnées
en sans plomb et en diesel c'est pour
cela qu'il ya des dizaines de voitures
qui attendent ici afin de pouvoir
acheter un petit peu d'essence depuis
plusieurs jours le pays connaît une
grave crise il est extrêmement difficile
d'acheter de l'essence aux kenyans et
les rares stations service qui en ont
encore et bien limite la vente à 2000
schilling c'est à dire environ 15 euros
insc une grave crise pour tous les
automobilistes pour les motos taxis pour
les bus je vous propose d'écouter
certains d'entre eux
people can get back loi qu eluana
d'ailleurs cette crise deux raisons
principales tout d'abord la guerre en
ukraine il faut savoir qu'ici au kenya
les prix à la pompe sont fixés par le
gouvernement et ils n'ont pas été
alignés sur la flambée des paris depuis
le début de la guerre en europe ensuite
il y a le fait que le gouvernement ici
finance les sens ils en paient une
partie aux compagnies importatrices mais
il a trois mois de retard de paiement et
donc ces sociétés et bien ont décidé de
ralentir voire de stopper leurs
importations alors pour tenter bien
d'endiguer le problème le président obo
kenyatta a annoncé ce lundi 34 milliards
de shillings dead à savoir 273 millions
d'euros pour tenter d'inverser la
situation difficile à dire pour l'heure
si cela aura un impact et si le kenya
aura de nouveau de l'essence au cours
des prochains jours
on en vient à la grève des footballeurs
professionnels au gabon ces derniers
refusent la reprise du championnat
prévue le 14 mai prochain un championnat
suspendu pendant deux ans pour cause de
covin 19 le gouvernement leur doit plus
d'un milliard de cfa soit 150 millions
d'euros pour exiger leur paiement les
joueurs observent un sit in depuis
quelques jours devant le ministère
gabonais des sports reportage d'erwan
tchèque 6 mélo bien pesés et alain
bakhita
nous avons le sucre confitures et
chocolats quelques vivre un peu de linge
et beaucoup de détermination
voilà de nombreux jours que souleymane
et ses collègues campent devant le
ministère des sports gabonais à
libreville des footballeurs en activité
ou au chômage réclamant le paiement d'au
moins 3 ans d'arriérés de salaire au
moins un milliard et demi de francs cfa
soit plus de 2 millions d'euros pour
plus de 700 joueurs jusqu'ici n'ont pas
obtenu gain de cause les championnats de
1re et 2e divisions doivent reprendre en
mai après deux ans d'interruption et
pense en fait que nous semble même un
lien que nous sommes des banques dit que
nous n'avons jamais été sur nos bancs de
l'école alors qu'elle ignore kessé nous
avons des gens qui ont porté nous avons
des gens qui ont porté le maillot de
l'équipe nationale de l'amertume pour
tous ces hommes comme souleymane après
13 ans au niveau il a décidé de
raccrocher les crampons pour travailler
dans le bâtiment
ce jour-là nous retrouvons l'ancien
joueur de 34 ans dans un restaurant
qu'il rénove souleymane s'est formé il y
a quelques mois et gagne désormais
quatre fois plus d'argent pour ce père
de famille terminées les salaires
impayés et les incertitudes du quotidien
lorsque tu joues pour une équipe qui
veut des résultats ben je sais pas ce
que tu vas manger en raclant tu sais pas
comment tu vas aller à l'entraînement
comment tu va repartir à la maison dites
moi quel est le genre de footballeur que
vous voulez produire
quelle est la motivation qu'un
footballeur va avoir de continuer à
jouer au football c'est pas possible ça
là c'est pour ceux qui rêvent le
mouvement de grève initié par certains
joueurs at il des chances de perturber
la reprise des deux championnats
nationaux
pour ces journalistes qui suivent
l'actualité mouvementée du football
gabonais quasiment aucune et ne sont que
quinze au 15 ou 20 au 30 alors que si on
avait en avait un effet de masse
important selon les autorités la dette
due aux joueurs leur sera payé après les
conclusions d'un audit financier auprès
de la fédération et des clubs un audit
démarré depuis septembre 2021 et qui
pourrait durer encore plusieurs mois
sans surprise c'est angélique kidjo qui
a remporté le grammy du meilleur album
musiques du monde avec l'opus mardi n'a
plus de quinze ans de carrière pour le
dj sud-africain black coffee a qui
remporte un grammy pour sa première
nomination
le grammy award du meilleur album dance
électro avec ce second chelsea
et on ouvre cette page consacrée à y
dire le chanteur kabyle on va parler de
la légende avec farid ali d'être qui
vient nous présenter son livre consacré
à l'artiste une biographie intitulée
idir un kabyle du monde merci beaucoup
farid d'être avec nous ce sont encore
parler votre livre bonsoir alors la
dernière fois vous étiez venu c'était en
2020 pour nous parler de bouteflika une
autre biographie ça n'a rien à voir
aujourd'hui mais j'ai envie de vous
poser la même question vous comment vous
est venue l'idée et comment vous avez
écrit ce livre
il y a des dizaines des centaines de
livres sur les beatles et elvis presley
sous john à l'idée mais a pas de libre
messieurs sur youtube et dire qui est
une icône de la musique kabyle et
algérienne est aussi quelqu'un qui a
fait partie du patrimoine du paysage
musical français donc il n'y a pas de
libre sur dives et donc je voulais aller
à la découverte de cet artiste dont la
carrière est passé un demi siècle pour
que je voulais de découvrir le faire
découvrir à la comté qui est dires de
l'artiste l'homme l'homme universel
alors dans ce livre il s'agit bien
évidemment dire c'est jean veut dire
l'acteur principal
mais pas seulement il dira c'est aussi
les lieux qu'il a fréquenté les gens
qu'il a côtoyés c'est l'histoire avec un
petit h 10 dire mais c'est aussi
l'histoire d'un grand h de l'acadie lit
de l'algérie on peut pas dissocier
idir l'homme ait idir le chanteur du
contexte dans lequel il a vécu sa di
stasio la kabylie algérie il a vécu les
nez juste après la seconde guerre
mondiale il a vécu la guerre d'algérie
dans sa chair ensuite il a peu vécu
l'indépendance de l'algérie ensuite les
années du socialisme du parti unique
ensuite il a vécu ici en france pendant
parce que cinquante ans qu'on peut pas
comprendre cette oeuvre monumentale est
dit si on revient pas à ce contexte
historique culturel aussi
alors il dira c'est aussi le défenseur
incontesté de la culture kabyles et
berbères d'ailleurs dans votre livre
d'autres personnages occupent une place
importante en parle de marguerite taos
amrouche en parle aussi de mameri
mouloud feraoun de matoub lounès il ya
toujours idir au centre parce que hisser
comme un espèce de fil conducteur dans
cette ce patrimoine cette identité
berbère cette langue berbère et
algériennes aussi patrimoine algérien
donc il a connu les gens que vous citez
taos amrouche mouloud mammeri
matoub lounès mais il a collé aussi
d'autres d'autres d'autres chanteurs de
la série t il aidé il a chanté avec
francis cabrel il a chanté avec charles
aznavour a chanté avec patrick bruel il
a chanté avec avec des avec le logo des
jo fait onema tout à l'heure vous city
indique qu'ils jouent il a chanté avec
une malienne qui était choriste de
angélique kidjo il a chanté avec des
boules temps il a chanté avec des
l'écossaise karen matheson donc
encore une fois c'est pas quelqu'un
qu'on peut réduire à la kabylie ou à
l'algérie c'est quelqu'un qui aspire
encore une fois qui a inspiré à
l'universalité il a chanté aussi avec
aznavour et il a fait chanter aznavour
en caddie et vous imaginez qu'il a fait
chanter ah non seulement à volants
kabyle mais il a fait chanter aussi
maxime le forestier en kabyle francis
cabrel en kabyle et patrick bruel en
cabine donc c'était quand même c'est
quand même un défenseur de la langue
berbère comme comme je le disais il ya
une autre question qu'on se pose en
lisant votre livre c'est que
ce personnage qui a quand on lit on se
rend compte qu'il est rentré dans la
musique avec pudeur avec à petit pas
par hasard presque mais qu'il est resté
tout au long de sa vie et de sa carrière
malgré ce succès est un personnage
discret et pudique
c'est tout le personnel dire autant et
les publics autant les gens pense le
connaître mais autant il est quelqu'un
de très pudique très singes traité eu
quelqu'un que vous aussi qui protège et
sa vie toute la difficulté aussi de
travailler sur un personnage comme ça
mais en fait et dire appartient à tout
le monde le sociologue pierre bourdieu
disait et dia n'est pas un chanteur
c'est ta mort de cinq familles chacun se
connaît dans les chansons des deals même
ceux qui ne connaissent pas qui
comprennent pas le kabyle tant que donc
voilà c'est un personnage attachant si
en fait c'est au delà du fait qu'il soit
un poète et un chanteur c'est comme le
frère c'est comme l'ami c'est comme le
père parfois même le grand air chacun se
connaît en fait si vous voulez c'est
pour paraphraser un peu la chanson du
jeune habitait houle a tous quelque
chose à dire
on a et on écoute et un petit peu vague
nova qui l'a rendue célèbre
quelle est votre chanson préférée dire
si toutefois vous en avez une c'est
difficile je pense que je pense elle
avait eu nova c'est la chanson c'est ma
chanson préférée il ya d'autres mais
c'est là parce qu'elle me parle autant
qu elle vous parlera vous autant qu'elle
parle à ceux qui à ceux qui qui ont
convenu dit il ceux qui n'ont pas connu
et donc
des vélos va c'est mon enfance aussi
parce que moi j'ai découvert il dira à
l'âge de
avant et il a fallu des années plus tard
pour que j'aille le découverte et la
découverte didier
on va malheureusement s'arrêter là on
n'a pas le temps de parler plus on
pourrait en parler pendant des heures
merci beaucoup farid ali dette un livre
vraiment à lire même pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas et dire qu'ils n'ont
jamais écouté sa musique c'est un livre
magnifique qui nous plonge dans son
histoire dans l'histoire de l'algérie et
d'autres personnages merci beaucoup
d'aléas d'être venu nous parler de votre
livre c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]